numerous steam machines debuted at CES
2014 but Alienware solution the Alpha
stood out from the pack
it wasn't an underpowered or rebranded
product and it also wasn't sitting next
to a four figure price tag galleon
where's little box was the most viable
looking console size and console priced
offering of the lot
yelling where began shipping the Alpha
late last year for five hundred and
forty nine dollars although it recently
cut that price down to four hundred and
ninety-nine the Alpha is still more
expensive than consoles but also fairly
cheap as far as gaming pcs go obviously
it's not as powerful as the
quintessential PC gaming tower but it
may give Sonia Microsoft's latest
consoles are run for their money with a
slightly overclocked 860m GPU based on
in videos GM 107 chip four gigabytes of
RAM and Intel's Core i3 at 2.9 gigahertz
the Alpha has all the makings of a good
entry level gaming PC the 5400 rpm hard
drive is a slight disappointment and
it's likely the source of some of the
alphas occasionally long load times
otherwise the rest of the components
make for a surprisingly capable gaming
PC given the alphas relatively low cost
while the Alpha can't fulfill the
desires of every PC gamer who dreams of
pushing graphics settings to Ultra that
doesn't mean that medium or high
settings are out of reach while you can
get away with these at 1080p in most
cases you may need to kick the outfit
down to 720p if you want to inch closer
to 60 frames per second and to take
advantage of greater lighting and
post-processing effects although alphas
GPU supports 4k output it can't
realistically play games at such a
demanding resolution despite its PC
roots the primary appeal of the Alpha is
like that of a console such as
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one in the
interest of competition let's see how
the Alpha stands up to Sony and
Microsoft's latest consoles though the
Alpha can't match the advanced hair
found in the PlayStation 4 version of
Tomb Raider it still handles the game
quite well with high settings at 1080p
staying well above 30 frames per second
though the difference is only noticeable
on occasion the office stands above the
Xbox one so far as titanfall is
concerned the Alpha struggled a bit with
watchdogs on high settings so we had to
dial the effects down a bit to hit a
reasonable frame rate at 1080p still
next to the PlayStation 4 version it's
hard to notice any major differences
Middle Earth shadow of Mordor could have
ran closer to 60 frames per second on
the Alpha with more conservative
settings but alien where's little blocks
stayed above 30 frames per second when
we turned on advanced stuff like ambient
occlusion
tesselation remaining totally playable
while looking good too these tests make
it clear that the Alpha is on average as
capable as PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
when it comes to sheer in-game
performance unlike those systems the
alphas RAM and CPU are upgradeable if
you spend a little more money you can
push the alpha further than we have in
our tests but at that point at about
$850
it may be worth investing in a
traditional PC with a stronger GPU
although some people refer to the Alpha
as a console it's driven by Microsoft
Windows a PC operating system and with
that the Alpha exhibits the same general
capabilities and limitations as any
other Windows gaming PC what is unique
about the Alpha and why some consider to
be a console is iliyan where's custom
user interface which boots up on top of
Windows and is 100% controller friendly
currently the Alpha has only integrated
valve scheme service within the UI this
is because steams big picture mode makes
it easy to access the marketplace in
your own library of games with only a
controller either EA's origin or
Ubisoft's you play touts a controller
friendly interface and while they are
still accessible through the alphas
Windows 8.1 desktop mode there is no way
to properly and seamlessly access games
purchased through those services within
alien wares custom UI in most cases
Ubisoft and EA games purchase directly
through Steam will work without problems
the only caveat you may need to make use
of the alphas virtual announcement every
alpha comes with a wireless Xbox 360
controller that with a simple hockey
combo can function as a mass using the
left analog stick it's handy when you
need it such as the initial setup when
you power on the Alpha for the first
time but the need for such a feature
reminds you that you are indeed using a
PC and not a system that's completely
controller friendly 100% of the time
apart from the backlit Alienware logo
the Alpha is rather unassuming and less
ostentatious than most of the alien
wares other systems if you don't like
the color of the default backlight or
you just want to turn off lights
completely you only need to hop into the
alphas settings menu and adjust the
color to your liking the Alpha has the
basics covered when it comes to
connectivity there are two USB 2.0 ports
in the front of the box two USB 3.0
ports on the back right next to Ethernet
optical audio and HDMI in and out ports
the HDMI import is an unusual feature
but similar to the Xbox one it lets the
alpha handle video pass-through from
another device such as a gaming console
or a blu-ray player the Alpha doesn't
offer experiences as composed or
seamless as a console but Alienware has
done a decent job of console izing the
PC outpacing the competition in some
very meaningful ways their UI creates
the illusion that your
using a console and it's a disappearing
act that works almost 100% of the time
but you can't tap into origin or you
play within the console mode you can if
you boot into the Windows desktop though
the Alpha isn't quite a console it
offers so much more as a PC than the
Xbox one or PlayStation 4 ever could
taking the Alpha out of the home theater
and putting it on a desk with a mouse
and keyboard opens a wealth of
functionality that can't be overlooked
apart from being able to upgrade the GPU
and motherboard you can do anything with
the Alpha that you could with an equally
powerful traditional desktop computer
with this in mind the Alpha is a great
value it may be more expensive and
consoles but the difference of $100 is a
small price to pay for a console like
gaming device that also doubles as a
Windows PC if you like the convenience
of the console experience are interested
in hundreds of excellent games that are
available on Steam and could benefit
from a new desktop $500 is a very
reasonable asking price true it may not
blow consoles out of the water when it
comes to performance but it does come
close manage your expectations
accordingly and you won't be
disappointed by the Alienware alpha
you